bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission que vous pourrez regarder à la
place d'aller en boîte ou entre deux
tesco vide c'est tout chaud
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ses
cages cette semaine on va passer en
revue l'actualité économique au sommaire
donc le variant omicron et les nouveaux
risques que ce variant fait peser sur
notre économie on parlera aussi du
nouveau credo fou de bercy après le quoi
qu'il en coûte
place aux quoi qu'il arrive on ira jeter
un oeil au commerce extérieur français
qui bat de l aile et puis enfin la
direction à la chine avec les géants de
l'immobilier toujours en difficulté pour
évoquer tous ces sujets olivier
delamarche évidemment bonjour religieux
seul bonjour pierre face à vous un
pierre bentata bonjour vous êtes maître
de conférences à l'université
aix-marseille bonjour et bienvenue dans
ces caches on va démarrer avec la crise
sanitaire qui s'éternise l'arrivée du
variant omicron et les contaminations
qui repartent à la hausse font peser un
risque sur certains secteurs économiques
tous les détails avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine vs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand il y en a plus y en a encore ce
n'est pas une première mais une fois de
plus alors que l'on pensait en avoir
fini avec le co vide le voilà de retour
avec un variant ou 12 noms de omicron
les contaminations sont repartis à la
hausse et les inquiétudes pour
l'économie aussi sur les marchés d'abord
dans la tente de savoir quelles seraient
les conséquences de ce nouveau variant
les marchés européens ont tous plonger
le cac 40 a par exemple chuté de 4 75%
le 26 novembre sa plus forte baisse
depuis mars 2020 avant finalement d'être
rassurés par une accélération de leurs
vaccinations enclenchée par les états en
france al'approche des fêtes de fin
d'année période charnière pour de
nombreux secteurs beaucoup craignent un
retour des restrictions et des
difficultés mais le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire est venu
rassurer tout le monde non omicron
n'aura pas d'impact sur la croissance
française bon on se méfiera quand même
parce que leurs élus 2020 il l'avait
évalué l'impact du coc vide à 0 1% de
croissance en moins avec le résultat
final que l'on connaît mais bon à cette
époque on ne savait pas grand chose de
ce qui nous attendait bruno le maire a
en tout cas répétés face aux inquiétudes
que de toute façon le quoi qu'il en
coûte c'était fini
place maintenant aux quoi qu'il arrive
quelle différence eh bien cette fois les
aides seraient ciblés étudier au cas par
cas en fonction des secteurs d'activité
en somme ce que beaucoup d'économistes
avaient réclamé dès le début de la
pandémie afin d'éviter de se retrouver
avec des entreprises privées perfusé
advitam eternam l'état
cela pourrait également s'accompagner
d'un report du remboursement des pg e
les prêts garantis par l'état déjà
repoussée plusieurs fois l'état
consentirait à attendre six mois de plus
à moins qu'un nouveau variant pie ou
sigma ne l'obligent à les repousser
encore et encore et encore
[Musique]
olivier r je vous entend des rires en
tiroir cash et ben vous entendez bien
parce que je pense que le problème c'est
pas au micron c'est au maquereau le
problème plutôt parce que c'est la
gestion ce virus s'est pas autre chose
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune preuve que
le au micron en question soit létale il
n'y a pas de morts du du variant au
micron c'est un fait c'est pas moi
qu'ils disent et les instituts nationaux
donc et internationaux donc aujourd'hui
ça n'est pas un problème alors même s'il
y a en effet des contaminations pour
l'instant c'est pas quelque chose qui
est dangereux donc arrêtons de faire
peur à tout le monde pour installer
petit à petit un pouvoir dictatorial
parce que c'est ce qui est en train
d'être faits c'est à dire que on vous
prive de liberté en vous faisant peur
mais pour l'instant il n'y a qu'une et
beurre à avoir
là je parle de au micron la fameuse
cinquième vague qui arrive et qui pour
l'instant ressemble plus à une
vaguelette qu'à une à une vague donc
soyons sérieux pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune preuve qu'ils soient les talent
il na aucune preuve qu'il envoie les
gens à l'hôpital donc arrêtons de faire
peur systématiquement à tout le monde et
en plus à nos enfants il ya tout de même
des contaminations étaient à 40 milles
oui c'est d'accord 4 sauf que 6,6 à des
contaminations et que c'est un rhume si
vous voulez on va pas bloquer non plus
le monde entier pour sahafa fois il faut
être un peu raisonnable et et sur le le
le sur la suite je l'espère parler mais
j'en parlerai aussi sur les soi-disant
mesures qui ne sont plus quoi qu'il en
coûte mais autrement appelée mais qui
ressemble quand même fortement servette
est à moi je vais vous faire réagir à
cette déclaration de bruno le maire les
places boursières sont toujours des
hypersensibles et des hyper réactive
notre devoir est de garder notre
sang-froid sang-froid pardon je n'ai pas
d'inquiétudes pour la croissance
française elle est solide et repose sur
des fondamentaux qui sont bons donc
déclaration je le disais de bruno le
maire alors qu'il était interrogé sur
les risques du variant omicron pour
l'économie française pas trop
d'inquiétude non plus du côté du
gouverneur de la banque de france les
impacts économiques devade des vagues
épidémiques successives ont été
jusqu'ici de moins en moins
préjudiciable est ce la signifie t'il
selon vous que notre notre économie
finalement s'adapte de vague en vague en
tout cas ce qui communique dessus
s'adapte bien des vagues en vagues ça
c'est ça c'est sûr mais on ne met alors
je me moque mais en fait on a un
désaccord de fond vous avez une bonne
partie des économistes qui pensent que
tout ce qui a été fait a été bien fait
que on a des structurellement l'économie
va bien que il ya le chômage a vraiment
été vaincue que le pib a augmenté puis
moi je fais partie de ceux qui sont
peut-être moins la plus orthodoxe haut
ou plus hétérodoxe en tout cas seul os
sur la théorie mais qui sont très
pessimistes moi je vois pas où sont les
fondamentaux qui sont bons je remarque
d2d dès le début des mesures d avril
2019 moi j'avais dit qu'il y avait là
une inflation qui étaient importantes il
se trouve qu'elle ne l'était pas dans
les chiffres mais on la voyait
maintenant tout le monde est d'accord
moi je dis qu'il ya du chômage qui est
des entreprises qui sont bien on verra
on verra ce que ce que dit l'avenir et
la cie résidents de gaza notre économie
finalement ben c'est que c'est alors
c'est pas que la nôtre mais c'est que de
toute façon le monde entier sous
perfusion là on a un vrai problème on en
avait parlé d'ailleurs il ya un an ici
on ne sait pas comment débrancher la
perfusion on n'a aucune idée donc on
peut changer les termes on peut essayer
de rassurer tout le monde mais sur le
fond il ya un problème
il ya un problème il n'y a pas de crise
alors qu'il n'y a pas de production donc
il ya quelque chose qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va pas et ça ça dure pas
indéfiniment donc je suis très
pessimiste mois sur l'aspect structurel
non je crois pas que l'économie aille
bien oui j'ai de quoi qu'il arrive on
l'a dit a désormais remplacé le quoi
qu'il en coûte ce ça ce sont des aides
ciblées donc est la crise est là pour
des secteurs comme l'événementiel ou les
traiteurs qui font face à de nombreuses
annulations d'événements au cas par cas
nous allons regarder chiffres à l'appui
ce que les annulations signifie sur les
chiffres d'affaires de ces secteurs
c'est ce qu'a expliqué le ministre de
l'économie finalement les aides ciblées
on y arrive enfin elle était réclamé ces
attaques ciblées oui mais elles sont
toujours pas ciblé j'ai entendu monsieur
mâcon qui nous disait qu' il allait
indemniser les boîtes de nuit accessible
et qui boîte de nuit donc bah non c'est
possible et c'est à dire ce que la coc
secteur on continue et vous avez une
poursuite des pg e vous avez une
poursuite donc qu'est-ce qui change rien
d'accord on continue exactement comme
avant alors il veut il veut bien nous
chante et qui cible mais quels sont les
critères pour pour cible et personne
n'en sait rien donc ça va être quoi ça
va être fait sur le coin d'une dune
d'une table dans un ministère jeudi les
îles sont incapables il était incapable
avant de déterminer les entreprises
qu'il fallait aider et celles qui ne
fallait pas aidé c'est pas aujourd'hui
alors qu'on leur a injecté énormément
d'argent qu'il va pouvoir faire la
différence entre une entreprise qui
était une entreprise avec un mauvais
modèle avant et une entreprise qui était
une entreprise viable et qui
fonctionnait avant donc ce qu'il a été
incapable de faire au début il est
toujours incapable de le faire parce que
c'est pas le ministère qui peut
déterminer genre de choses et donc je
suis désolé mais ça il ne va rien
changer je suis d'accord avec pierre sur
les fondamentaux alors il est tout
content parce que ils voient la bourse
remontée et îles d'hyères bassila bourse
remonte c'est que les fondamentaux sont
bons ben non justement le problème c'est
que la bourse elles montrent simplement
parce que il les banques centrales
injectent de l'argent donc c'est les
banques centrales qui sont alors là pour
le coup le meilleur vaccin anti baisse
de démarches et ça pour le coup on la
trouvait et ça fonctionne parfaitement
bien donc voila mais ça ne veut pas dire
pour ça que les fondamentaux économiques
sont bons aujourd'hui nous avons des
fondamentaux économiques qui sont
purement dégradé pourquoi parce que la
réindustrialisation de monsieur le maire
elle n'existe pas dans les faits que
vous avez vous avez des d'une croissance
qui est extrêmement faible alors on vous
annonce 1 6% mais on vous annonce 1 6%
parce qu'il ya un effet de base c'est
tout et puis parce que on déverse aussi
de l'argent et que donc quand vous
déversez comme ça et que vous vous
endettez pour faire
5 10
% de déficit budgétaire
évidemment que vous avez un
résidu qui arrive en pipe et
heureusement mais bon c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on aime ce qu'on avait dit dans la
dernière émission c'est pas du tout un
effet de levier c'est un effet massue
qu'on a et donc il faut arrêter de
prendre les gens pour des imbéciles et
leur annoncer à chaque fois que demain
l'herbe est plus verte parce que demain
malheureusement l'herbe elle est moche
on met d'accord avec ce qu'il
ya trop il ya trois choses d'abord c'est
vrai sur le pib s'est c'est une arnaque
quoi cette communication mais c'est mais
pas que le gouvernement tout le monde
dans lé plein de journalistes aussi nous
dit super si vous avez perdu 15% et que
vous gagnez 6% en fait vous êtes parvenu
au point de départ si vous avez perdu
celle inverse de l'effet soldes où on
vous augmente les prix de 30 et puis on
les baisse de 10 au bout du regardez
c'est moins cher donc ça c'est ça c'est
ça c'est pas bon comme communication la
deuxième chose c'est vrai les marchés
financiers on le sait on a on a
maintenant plein d'études qui nous
montre toutes les places boursières sont
indexés en fait à la production de
monnaie de la fed donc bon bah quand la
fed produits de la monnaie le marché
boursier va bien et ça il n'y a plus
aucun rapport avec ce qui se passe
réellement et même même les nôtres et
puis le plus important c'est qu'au delà
même des fondamentaux français c'est
l'économie mondiale qui va pas bien et
là on se retrouve avec
il ya une école qui détestait en france
parce qu'elle est considéré comme
libéral l'école d'economie autrichienne
mais il faut regarder leurs modèles ils
nous montraient bien pas ce qui est en
train de se passer il l'avait très bien
prévu pourtant ils ont prévu dans les
années 60 vous laissez les gens
consommaient vous aider la consommation
vous aider toutes les entreprises qui
sont en train de produire normalement
des biens finaux donc face aux
consommateurs en même temps vous fermez
l'économie et vous continuez à financer
ce qui se passe dans la production bas
mécaniquement dans la chaîne de valeur
dans la chaîne de production toute
l'industrie logistique elle est
complètement déposséder elle est au
moment où ça redémarre il ya une
consommation qui est très forte une
demande qui est très fort donc à des
prix qui augmentent mais en fait il n'ya
pas de valeur qui a été créée en phase
donc la demande grimpe mais on n'a pas
les produits pour faire face à ça et on
le voit partout on a eu les pénuries
d'énergie pénurie de matières premières
les semi conducteurs maintenant on à
nike qui nous dit non je peux pas honoré
mais mais mais commandes de décembre le
prix des containers lui-même augmente
donc en fait c'est toute l'économie qui
va pas bien là on a voulu redémarrer une
machine en croyant qu'il suffisait
d'appuyer sur le bouton on off mais en
réalité non vous avez des gens qu'on a
fait survivre et qui maintenant ont les
moyens de consommer mais en face il n'y
a pas de contrepartie en termes de
valeur donc oui là il ya de la monnaie
mais mais rien d'autre vous évoquez
aussi les marchés le vario au micro non
la jura a mis les bourses sont dessus
dessous le cac 40 par exemple a connu en
quelques jours sa plus forte baisse
depuis sa plus forte hausse de l'année
ça veut dire que justement prévu sur les
marchés les semaines qui viennent là
elles feront elles sont décisives non je
crois pas je crois pas parce qu'en fait
on peut largement les relancer les
marchés ils sont complètement
déconnectés du monde réel donc il n'y a
pas de souci il ya juste un effet de
bulle un effet de spéculation ou là y'a
vraiment il n'y a aps en fait tout
l'argent qui est produit par les banques
centrales il est là donc et aider les
banques commerciales peuvent peuvent
aussi jouer donc on va on arrive à
fabriquer plein de monnaie donc on peut
arriver à faire monter en épingle et on
crée une bulle énorme où tout fonctionne
et dès qu'elles menacent d'exploser on
remet au pot donc c'est pas très grave
le problème c'est que par contre
maintenant la politique monétaire elle
est entièrement dépendante de ça on a
assez de la politique champagne quad et
que la bulle a explosé il faut vite en
refaire une donc c'est pas très grave en
soi mais par contre ça ne veut plus rien
dire sur l'économie réelle mais bien un
mot rapidement sur les marchés avant la
traditionnelle mans si vous voulez mois
de décembre c'est la période ce qu'on
appelle les window dressing c'est à dire
que
on arrange le le bilan et pour arranger
le bilan on tire sur certains titres il
ya certains types qui sont un peu
laissés en arrière et puis d'autres qui
finissent avec
10 15% de hausse sur le mois de décembre
pas du tout parce qu'ils vous ont
annoncé des choses merveilleuses
simplement parce que voilà il faut que
ça finisse à un cours et
il ça finira un cours quoi qu'il arrive
d'accord mais si on marque une courte
pause on se retrouve dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez une émission consacrée à
l'actualité économique de la semaine et
pour en parler nous sommes avec pierre
bentata maître de conférences à
l'université aix marseille on va parler
chats présents commerce extérieur avec
les chiffres du déficit qui ne sont pas
bons le déficit du commerce extérieur
français pourrait s'élever à 95
milliards d'euros en 2022 cela
correspond à 3 7% du pib contre 86
milliards en 2021 une augmentation de
près de 10 milliards donc en un an un
rapport du haut commissariat au plan a
été publié le 7 décembre dernier ce
rapport appellent à faire de ce sujet
une priorité nationale proche de
l'équilibré au début des années 2000 le
solde commercial de la france a commencé
à se creuser en 2004 on est passé d'un
modèle de consommation et non de
production explique le document olivier
qu'est ce que ça signifie concrètement
ces décrocheurs ce décrochage il est là
depuis longtemps je vous rappelle que
l'italie qu'on a montré du doigt pendant
des mois et des mois un solde positif 65
milliards je crois quelque chose dans ce
goût là
que vous avez l'allemagne évidemment
grande gagnante et ya un solde largement
positif mais pour ça il faut avoir un
peu d'industries chez soi par exemple
et puis
malheureusement la france depuis depuis
longtemps joue contre elle même donc
qu'aujourd'hui on en fasse une cause
nationale était bien avant qu'il aurait
fallu en faire une cause nationale il se
poser la question pourquoi des pays qui
sont quand même du même du même acabit
que le nôtre du même ordre que le nôtre
comme l'italie
un solde positif et nous on n'arrive
toujours pas à sortir d'un déficit alors
là on s'en étonne parce que il est en
effet passé à pas loin de 100 milliards
mais on a traîné des déficits entre 40
et 50 milliards tous les ans depuis x
temps donc je ne suis pas étonné alors
bien fait état dans ce rapport françois
bayrou le haut commissaire au plan donne
l'exemple des pommes de terre la france
est le premier exportateur mondial de
pommes de terre mais écrit-il nous
sommes gravement déficitaire en chips
flocons purée et sur d'autres produits
transformés du même secteur
agroalimentaire même chose pour le bois
on exporte du bois que l'on réimportent
en produits transformés comment en gros
sortir de cette spirale en ré enregistré
dix ans par exemple n'ont pas forcé pas
forcément alors moi je suis pas du tout
inquiet du commerce international vous
pouvez très bien de quand vous regardez
le top 10 des puissances mondiales vous
avez la moitié qui est un déficit et
l'autre moitié un excédent ne soit pas
très grave tout dépend en partie ce cas
là dedans quoi et là le problème c'est
quand vous n'êtes vraiment pas
compétitif avec avec des choses qui sont
très faciles à transformer le pire
exemple je trouve c'est la viande bovine
où on est capable de vendre à des
allemands qui ne passe qui leur achètent
plus chers que ceux qui rachèterait les
français qui le transforme et leur
vendent moins chers en france que ce que
ferait des français donc là notre
problème c'est surtout les coûts de
notre économie il ya quelque chose on
n'est pas du tout efficace plus que
parler de compétitivité en termes
d'import-export notre problème c'est
qu'on paie pas productif là et là il
faut se poser les questions qu'est ce
qui dans la machine économique fait que
on est on coûte aussi cher par rapport
au rendement on est capable de fournir
est ce que par exemple ça pourrait vous
une baisse des impôts de production
pourrait permettre les impôts de
production c'est vraiment alors s'est
passé pas l'alpha et l'oméga même si on
en parle beaucoup mais c'est quand même
catastrophique l'impôt de production
c'est ce qui est le plus injuste et plus
stupide en même temps vous tapez sur une
entreprise avant même qu'elle ait fait
du profit et tous ses coups en fait pèse
exactement pareil que de la queue de la
masse salariale c'est quasiment le coût
fixe en réalité qui s'impose à votre
entreprise on l'a chiffrée ça d'ailleurs
avec un avec un think tank avec
l'institut molinari vous baisser de 60
milliards les les coûts de production en
fait vous êtes gagnants dont qui y vit
ça évidemment il faut le faire mais ce
n'est pas la seule chose c'est qu'en
fait en termes de coût du travail en
termes de friction il ya des vrais
problèmes on a des industries et des
chaînes de valeur en fait qu'ils sont
pas correctement intégrées qui sont
mieux intégrés avec quelle étrange les
que chez nous c'est tout le problème
d'accord je suis d'accord mais le
problème c'est que c'est vraiment un
problème de fond c'est à dire qu'on
chasse les entreprises depuis longtemps
parce que parce que c'est mal vu de 2,2
de monter une entreprise en france c'est
mal vu de faire travailler des gens
c'est mal vu de gagner de l'argent c'est
mal vu donc évidemment au bout d'un
moment
les entrepreneurs à et bas ils vont
faire leur entreprise ailleurs et donc
évidemment c'est un c'est un problème et
c'est pour ça que le voeu pieux de faire
revenir les entreprises en france ne
restera jamais qu'un voeu pieux parce
que tant qu'on ne transforme pas les
conditions pour lesquelles elles sont
parties finalement eh bien vous avez
aucune chance qu'elle revienne elle est
la dernière actualité de la semaine
c'est la chine avec le géant immobilier
evergrande qui n'auraient pas réussi
cette fois à payer à ses créanciers
informations de l'agencé bloomberg ce
serait donc le premier défaut de
paiement d'evergrande les aps le
promoteur a annoncé la création d'un
comité de gestion de risque cinq
responsables d'entreprises publiques y
siégeront en d'autres termes l'état
chinois et qu'est-ce que ça traduit
olivet cette intervention de pékin
à écouter on a fait une émission là
dessus il ya quelques temps où on disait
que où je disais que le c'était en fait
une reprise en main d'un d'un énième
secteur puisque je vous rappelle que
jacques m'a avait fait un petit tour
on sait pas où d'ailleurs mais pendant
quelques semaines pour ce faire
rééduquer probablement et donc vous avez
vous avez une reprise en main de l'état
chinois alors là évidemment vous avez 7
cet énorme foncière mais on le savait je
veux dire c'est une surprise pour
personne
on savait qu'il y avait des villes
entières qui étaient des gosses tonnes
donc des villes qui n'était pas peuplé
du tout on construisait une pipe à une
pas village est une ville comme comme
comme une capitale occidentale et vous
aviez personne dedans donc évidemment le
promoteur qui a fait ça à un moment ça
devient compliqué pour lui bon donc on
savait qu'il y avait énormément de dette
qui était de la dette pourrie et que à
un moment ou à un autre ça allait
ressortir mais qu'est ce qui est en
train de se passer en fait la réalité je
pense que le l'état chinois est en train
de reprendre la main dessus il va régler
le problème très probablement en interne
parce que il veut pas avoir de deux
soulèvements ou problème avec avec les
chinois bien qu'ils règlent le problème
assez
c'est durement quelquefois mais là ils
vont donc payer les dettes en interne
j'ai pas de jets pas de doute là dessus
il suffit de faire tourner un tout petit
peu la planche à billets et finalement
il ya cette solution miracle qui est
utilisé partout dans le monde je vous
propose que les chinois ne l'utiliserai
pas et en revanche à ceux qui sont de
l'extérieur c'est-à-dire les
investisseurs de l'extérieur qui ont des
dettes evergrande je serais assez
inquiet à leur place bon parce que ils
sont pas obligés du tout de les
rembourser et là vous aurez
traditionnellement les grandes banques
qui ont toutes trouvé malin d'aller
acheter des bêtes pourri et qui vont se
retrouver avec des trous mais
rassurez-vous là aussi les banques
centrales occidentales feront tourner un
tout petit peu la planche à billets
pourrait pour sauver ses banques qui ont
fait de mauvais investissements donc
finalement tout va bien 27 à vous quel
regard vous portez à sur cette dernière
étape on l'a fait rêver en grand je
trouve que c'est un c1 c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est un signal
faible de la mauvaise santé économique
de la chine contrairement à ce qu'on
n'aurait pas de nous répéter le grand
géant la future grande puissance là il
souffre exactement d'une mauvaise
administration économique ce qui
s'appelle un effet d'accordéon vous avez
inciter les gens à lot a trop produire
vous avez fait marcher trop de dettes et
un moment le marché s'effondre parce que
la personne pour acheter vos produits
mais quand vous avez ce à l'échelle de
la chine d'abord c'est énorme vous avez
quelqu'un qui est considéré quasiment
comme un leader mondial et là vous
apercevez que ça va pas bien et on
s'aperçoit que finalement cette économie
mixte dont nous parlent et qu'ils
étaient super avec comme en france
d'ailleurs avec une administration au
plan à commissariat au plan et une sorte
d'économie de marché à côté ça marche
pas il ya un moment où il faut choisir
et donc là je trouve c'est très
intéressant parce que ça va nous montrer
à quel point finalement la chine va pas
si bien que ça on ferait bien de faire
très attention ces temps ci c'est notre
seul fournisseur on reste avoir des
problèmes dans les années à venir pierre
la dette est pas un problème donc le
problème c'est que c'est à la fin c'est
plus la tête quand les gens n'ont pas de
maisons mobiles maison que m $ comme
c'était le cas à détroit parce que c'est
ça qui sont en train de refabriquer on
peut avoir la dette qu'on veut que quand
ça correspond plus à des produits ou à
des vrais matière pour avoir tous les
billets que vous voulez vous n'avez pas
de vaccin ou vous n'avez pas de
nourriture donc c'est là le risque mais
personne sort n'est étonné mais à un
moment il ya eu un surinvestissement de
la chine par rapport à son pib on
n'avait jamais vu nulle part ailleurs
même les japonais au temps où jeter
l'argent par les fenêtres ça n'était
jamais arrivé à ce niveau là est donc
évidemment on est en train de payer la
différence merci olivier merci beaucoup
pierre bentata d'avoir été parmi nous je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université aix marseille
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une émission consacrée aux briques citer
un nom après que olivier place aux
commentaires et questions cash
commentaires olivier à dozos mattely
l'accroissement de la valeur des actifs
nets elle n'est elle pas une illusion vu
que la monnaie perd de sa valeur oui
c'en est une c'en est une mais c'en est
une qu'il faut qu'il faut entretenir
parce que
c'est une vitrine en fait le le labour
s'est donc et aujourd'hui on vous a dit
plusieurs fois ici que les banques
centrales
n'avaient plus le choix elle n'avait pas
de plan b elle ne pouvait plus revenir
en arrière donc aujourd'hui elles sont
obligées de soutenir les marchés dès que
vous remarquerez que dès que le marché
pour une raison x ou y peu importe dès
que le marché recule vous avez à ce
moment là des injections massives de
liquidités qui arrivent pour soutenir
les marchés dont ils sont devenus ce
qu'on appelle marc est dépendante et non
plus data dépendantes ce que doit être
une banque centrale la banque centrale
elle doit réagir à des stimuli
économiques et non pas de marché et là
il se trouve que depuis déjà plusieurs
années on est dans cette dans ce modèle
là qui est un modèle qui consiste à en
permanence faire monter les marchés donc
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est imprimé
arrive en fait sur les marchés et non
pas dans l'est que dans l'économie
réelle les fait monter ne fait pas
monter d'ailleurs que puisqu'ils font
monter aussi au passage les
le marché immobilier est aussi et ça
pose des problèmes pour pour que les
gens puissent se loger et serra et aussi
les marchés des matières premières
aujourd'hui on a des prix sur certaines
matières premières qui ne sont pas dus
du tout à une augmentation de la demande
qui sont simplement dus à de la
spéculation sur le marché sur les
marchés financiers donc ces marchés
financiers nous apporte aussi de
l'inflation et donc font en effet
descendre la valeur de la monnaie merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez
vous elle la semaine prochaine en
approuvant n'oubliez pas de laisser à
vos commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag rt est cachée olivier le
dernier mot vivement qu'on trouve un
vaccin contre les mauvaises nouvelles
parce que sinon j'ai peur que ça dure